but let's bump up a level and talk about
what you might want to use local storage
to store as I mentioned before you
probably want to use it to store user
settings but any data that may be useful
in a different session of your
application it's probably useful to cash
in index DB or local storage finally an
important way to think of this is
anytime you call a network API you
probably want to cash that response in
index DB or local storage so you can get
it back later when you're offline this
can be particularly useful because you
already have the data from a previous
session cashed in our conference app for
example each of the data models is being
loaded from a JSON file on the server in
the original incarnation these files are
loaded every time they're needed just
relying on HTTP caching to minimize the
network transfers when I initially made
an appt cash for the conference app and
just app cache the JSON files since of
course they need be there to run the
application however it would make more
sense to cache the data herein index
database for a couple of reasons first
it can do index lookups so I can have a
table for speakers a table for sessions
have them easily cross-reference items
in each of them and make it easy to
search for an entry secondly we can get
the structured data directly out of the
database rather than having to parse the
json text file each time we can then
provide a synchronization system that
occasionally makes Network requests to
refresh the data objects or updates on
load or when an unrecognized speaker is
found one final reminder though keep in
mind as you design your application that
if the user clears their data from the
machine any data stored locally is going
to be deleted so you shouldn't store the
only copy of important data on the
client local storage is really just
intended to be used as a cash